PROFESSOR: I
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: I think,
collectively, I did not
hear the full-fledged
justification
of the precautionary principle.
And I think that
focusing on the fact
that its application
would be the greatest
good for the greatest
number of people
is probably manifestly
wrong because I
think there are plenty
of instances where
being precautionary
means that you look out
for subgroups or
sub effects which
in fact, are very unlikely.
In a world of
certainty, one can argue
utilitarian ethics applies.
If you ban a chemical, you're
going to have a certain cost
and you going to have
a certain benefit.
As soon as the cost
becomes uncertain,
or the benefit
which is related
to risk assessment
because the benefit of
controlling the chemical
is derived from doing some
sort of risk assessment
which has high
uncertainties in it.
But it's not the only thing
that has uncertainties.
Costs have uncertainties, too.
So as soon as you depart
from a well-defined benefit
and a well-defined cost.
Utilitarian ethics is no
longer important because what's
important is how you value the
mistakes that you could make.
A type I error comes when you've
failed to regulate something,
and it later comes
out to be worse
than you thought or at the tails
of the distribution of what
you're thinking.
A type II error is
where you regulate,
and things turn out to be
not as bad as you thought
and then impose a
higher cost upon.
But there's a type
III error which
is you're working on
the wrong problem.
And I think that's
what you all really.
Missed the point is that
when you ban a chemical,
that isn't all that happens.
What happens is you
end up coming face
to face with a substitute,
with an alternative technology,
with alternative ways to
meet the public needs.
And so a straight
cost-benefit analysis,
even with uncertainty, unless
it includes the alternatives
that you have is not
a complete analysis.
And you can make
anything look good
depending upon how you value
life or value the environment.
And so the precautionary
principle, properly,
which is which applies when
you have great uncertainties,
has to ask the
question, what are
the alternatives to the action
that you've decided to promote.
There are alternatives.
There are there substitutes
I'll give you one more comment.
I know the word of
Cass Sunstein well.
I graduated from
[INAUDIBLE],, same law school.
I think he is a poor scholar.
He does not understand.
SPEAKER 1: You heard it here.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND:
He does not really
understand what this
whole issue was about,
has never really understood it.
For example, people say, suppose
you regulate vinyl chloride.
You put worker controls
on vinyl chloride.
And the workers now
earn a smaller salary
because the vinyl
chloride producer
can't afford to pay them.
So what do they do?
They quit their health clubs.
They buy less lean hamburger.
And the health impact,
is argued by Sunstein,
is worse than if you
regulated the hazard
because you made
the workers poor.
And they eat fat hamburger
and don't exercise.
But that doesn't
take into account
the fact that when you regulate
vinyl chloride, what replaces
it, let's say, is polyethylene.
So those industries
increase production,
increase the wages of their
workers, who now join health
clubs and lean hamburgers.
Now if you're really going
to take this calculus
to the extreme, you
could see how ridiculous
it is because you
can't really determine.
But what you can determine
and what regulation
shows, when it's stringent,
you don't make marginal changes
in production.
You may see serious
shifts in the nature
of industrial policy.
And you shift to
nonchemical alternatives.
For example, the banning
of CFCs didn't just
supply one inhalant which
was slightly better.
People started to use pump cans.
You sell less
product, then that's
too bad for the producer.
But you don't need to
inhalant to deliver
deodorant or those things.
So it is narrowly defined.
You work on the wrong
problem, and you ignore how
you feel about air avoidance.
That's when the precautionary
principle comes in.
SPEAKER 1: Beautiful.
AUDIENCE: --go along with
it, slash bring up that point
that I think there is a middle
ground where with some things
I think we should
look into alternatives
and have them as backseat
if we find that whatever
precautionary didn't work out.
I think it's really dangerous to
just ignore other alternatives.
Like the Susskind article
said, going with that action
leads to unintended things that
maybe could've been a benefit.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: Take the
global warming situation.
This middle ground, I
think, is a fiction.
You either have to regard the
probability of serious global
impacts as within the realm
of possibility, or you don't.
Even people who aren't
certain about the science,
you ask them the
question, should we
plan for a rising sea level?
Should we plan for
floods and droughts
would be a bad thing to do.
And the answer
invariably comes, no, it
should be a good thing to do.
And if you act in
a timely fashion,
even if you turn
out to be wrong,
imagine what would
happen if you turned out
to be right and turn out
to have the coastal cities
disappearing [INAUDIBLE].
I think the
precautionary principle's
been criticized
by people who have
an economic dog in that
fight, that it's too expensive
and their particular
industry will disappear.
But the alternative is to
have, generally, other people
bear the cost.
So who bears the cost
and who reaps the benefit
of the decided policy?
It's very important.
And the distributional effects
of going one way or the other
are really serious.
If you decide to put a carbon
tax on oil, let me tell you,
the petroleum
industry will survive.
If you don't put a
carbon tax on the floor,
it's not clear that the
planet will survive.
So if they ask whose
ox is being gored,
how certain are we that you are
producing an irreducible effect
of these people.
And do you want to
keep your options open?
So I reject the fact that
what you're trying to do
is find a middle ground.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: But
I want to turn the dial,
as a last note, one more tick
beyond what Nick just said.
I believe, take the
climate change example,
that if you say, let's
take this seriously
because it might happen
that a whole series
of second and third
order decisions
can get made that, in fact,
wouldn't get made otherwise.
It's related to the point
you're making first.
And that will create
all kinds of benefits
because if people don't do
it to create these benefits,
they'll do it to
create benefits.
But they never
would have searched.
They never would've tried, They
never would've looked there.
So when we talk to communities
about taking various moves
to manage potential
climate risks,
and once you do it
in a way that creates
all kinds of other second
and third order benefits now,
instead of just looking
at what the costs are
and arguing that the long
term benefits outweigh
the short-term
costs, my argument
is why don't you try to do
something that deals with those
risks and creates all kinds
of short-term benefits.
And that becomes a
design consideration
in formulating the policy.
And if you can't do
it, you can't do it.
But I would argue
that the problem
with the precautionary
principle is it doesn't link to,
and let's look at ways of using
this theory that we're not
going to do something.
I told you the story about the
central Arctic and fisheries
question.
You can use a
period of time to do
more scientific investigation
that might in fact lead
us to understand
better ways of using
those resources as opposed
to, oh my god, we're scared.
A bad thing could happen.
It might only be a 1% chance.
But, oh my god, if
it happens horrible,
horrible things will
affect us in the future.
So let's not do it.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: But the
precautionary principal
has been linked to
alternatives analysis.
Now nobody doesn't ask,
what are the alternatives.
And by the way, the big failure,
Bush and Cheney decided,
we're going to get
Saddam before he gets us.
He was operating under
precautionary principle.
Look what the application of
that precautionary principle
brought us.
SPEAKER 1: If you
only say, let's
look at alternatives,
that's not the same as let's
search for alternatives--
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: Right.
SPEAKER 1: --that
both reduce the risk
and create a variety
of alternatives.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: And
develop those alternatives.
SPEAKER 1: And let's
be clear about trying
to distribute the benefits
of those alternatives
in a progressive way.
You could add that, too.
Anyway.
Thank you both for coming.